[Musica]
e per me un onore essere qui oggi e mi
sembra stranissimo essere su questo
tappeto rosso
se penso che fino a dieci anni fa la mia
vita a ruota intorno alla vela
passavo tutto il mio tempo libero in
mare non solo le giornate calde
meravigliosa dell'estate siciliana ma
anche quelle fredde invernali e ricordo
come fosse ieri la sensazione di avere
le mani piedi completamente congelati
alla fine degli allenamenti invernali e
devo ammettere che ero così prese dalla
vela che non meno nemmeno accorta che
fosse arrivato internet uno dei miei
primi incontri con internet è stato
quando ho preparato la tesina delle
scuole superiori
ricordo che non sapevo ancora bene come
cercare le immagini online e alla fine
sono finita a fotocopiare delle immagini
da libri della biblioteca e appiccicate
con la colla sua tesina perché non si
può ancora con cercare le immagini e e
inserirle testo scritto al computer
in dieci anni la mia vita è stata
stravolta dalla rivoluzione digitale
internet è stato il mio ponte a dalla
sicilia al resto del mondo
ma il momento che mi ha veramente aperto
gli occhi sulla rivoluzione digitale è
stato qualche anno più tardi quando
scoperto la stampa iii d e l'ho scoperta
proprio guardando un tetto quello di
anthony atala questo professore parlava
della stampa 3d di organi umani e della
promessa di salvare la vita di centinaia
di migliaia di persone con questa
tecnologia
una cosa fantastica è per me
assolutamente fantascientifica quei
tempi mi ha incuriosito tanto che ha
deciso di vedere una stampante 3d con i
miei occhi e sono stata fortunata che
trovare un corso di stampa 3d a
bruxelles la città dove vivevo quei
tempi la descrizione di questo corso mi
rassicurava perché diceva che chiunque
perfino una persona come me che la sua
economia
volevo imparare a stampare in 3d in
poche ore e quindi mi sono buttata e ho
fatto bene a buttarmi perché quel corso
in poche ore mi ha permesso di creare un
portachiavi col mio nome stampato in 3d
non era stampa di organi ma era stampa
in plastica semplicemente però quelle
quel portachiavi e bastato per far
vedere la tecnologia con occhi diversi
come uno strumento di creazione
piuttosto è come qualcosa da utilizzare
passivamente e quello è stato per me è
l'inizio di un percorso che mi ha
portato a qualche anno più tardi a
fondare una startup specializzata di
stampa 3d per dentisti e anche a fondare
il progetto things kids che vorrei
condividere oggi con voi sapranno su
questo progetto da tre anni con un team
fantastico di volontari che come me
avevano voglia di investire sul futuro
della sicilia e di riportare in sicilia
quello che avevano scoperto nel loro
percorso in giro per il mondo insieme
stiamo creando un ponte che porti gli
studenti in sicilia a contatto diretto
con l'innovazione nel resto nel mondo e
vogliamo mostrare e portare una vicina
della tecnologia come uno strumento
attivo di creazione
l'idea di questo progetto è nata vedendo
in prima persona quando fosse profondo
il divario tra realtà innovative come
quella di silicon valley e altre realtà
doc come la sicilia dove la tecnologia
viene subita più che creata alla base di
questo divario c'è innanzitutto il fatto
che oggi ci sono pochi creatori digitali
per esempio delle comunità online si
parla della regola dell'un per cento
c'è così tanto l'un per cento degli
utenti di una comunità sono creatori di
contenuti ma tutti gli altri sono
contributori e soprattutto consumatori
passivi dei contenuti creati a qualcun
altro
viviamo in un mondo in cui pochi creano
contenuti e servizi consumati da milioni
o miliardi di persone e le cose più
preoccupante è che non solo ci sono
pochi creatori della tecnologia digitale
ma anche questi pochi creatori sono
concentrati in alcuni stati e nelle
grandi città
questa concentrazione di creatori e il
divario in generale tra i creatori
tecnologia e i consumatori passivi la
tecnologia
secondo me è uno dei problemi più grandi
del 21esimo secolo e rischia di creare
profonde diseguaglianze economiche
politiche e sociali
credo sia un problema in cui che
dobbiamo risolvere adesso e gli
insegnerà risolvere a partire da oggi e
in questa transizione verso il mondo
digitale i nativi digitali sono
specialmente vulnerabili e non è quello
che non avente pensiamo che sono nati
col digitale quindi sono naturalmente
più vicino al digitale perché di fatto
questo
questi giovani sono nati in un mondo in
cui internet è dato per scontato e
spesso non viene messa in discussione
se vediamo i nostri chi legge nelle
scuole oggi molti di loro sono
utilizzare internet in maniera passiva e
sono utilizzare social media e instagram
ma quanti di questi studenti siano
utilizzare internet in maniera attiva
per creare contenuti o per sviluppare
idee imprenditoriali o per risolvere i
problemi sociali ma non sono qui per
parlarvi di quanto secondo me sia
urgente una riforma il sistema educativo
in italia penso che siamo tutti
d'accordo sul fatto che il nostro
sistema educativo ancora non si è
adattato alla rivoluzione digitale e che
non sta formando creatori protagonisti
nell'era digitale
se non ovviamente in alcuni casi
eccezionali sono qui per parlarvi di
come credo che tutti noi nel nostro
piccolo possiamo contribuire a risolvere
questo problema e possiamo farlo
partendo dal basso dalla nostra realtà
locale anziché aspettare qualcuno
dall'alto riformi il sistema educativo
nel nostro caso siamo partiti da marsala
la città dove sono cresciuta
nell'estrema punta occidentale della
sicilia
immagino anche alcuni di voi conoscono
marsala per il nostro vino ma immagino
anche che non molti sapranno che marsala
è anche la città del vento con
tantissimi appassionati di vela come me
penso che ci siano tre ingredienti
fondamentali per diventare buoni velisti
che sono gli stessi tre ingredienti che
utilizziamo del progetto team for kids
il primo ingrediente e la pratica fare
vela si impara veleggiando non suoi
libri si diventa buoni melissi
buttandosi in mare con tutte le
condizioni con le cadute le risalite in
barca le ricadute con i pianti quando ti
senti perso in mezzo al mare con le
vittorie e con le sconfitte e passando
ore ore a contatto con il mare
il secondo ingrediente e il team quando
ci si allena in un team si cresce
insieme quando facevo bel ricordo che
vedevamo ogni allenamento con una
piccola gara si imparava dei più grandi
e si insegnano ai più piccoli con il
team giusto si arriva insieme al
traguardo il terzo ingrediente e
l'ambiente marsala e la città con
condizioni ideali per fare vela tanto
vento un mare meraviglioso che fa venire
voglia di non scendere mai dalla barca e
temperature che permettono
anzi tutto l'anno questi tre ingredienti
la pratica il team l'ambiente sono i tre
ingredienti del progetto team for kids
partiamo dal primo la pratica se vostra
figlia vdb dicesse che vuole diventare
la velista le comprereste mai un libro
spero di no
la vela si impara in acqua e lo stesso
modo la tecnologia si impara toccandola
con mano usando la e non solo sui libri
se vogliamo i nostri studenti di ventino
creatori devono imparare a toccare la
tecnologia con mano e saperlo stato in
maniera attiva
non è importante che apprendono una
tecnologia specifica perchè comunque
qualsiasi cosa prenderò apprendono oggi
sarebbe obsoleta tra qualche anno
e importante invece che apprendono una
visione della tecnologia come lo
strumento di creazione e oggi possiamo
trasmettere questa visione della
tecnologia attraverso le macchine di
fabbricazione digitale come la stampante
3d e il taglio laser
immagino che a cui voi non hanno mai
visto una stampante 3d e immagino che
pensiate che siano care e difficili da
utilizzare è in realtà non è così
la pubblicazione digitale negli ultimi
anni è diventata sia finanziariamente
che anche tecnicamente molto accessibile
e qualsiasi scuola oggi potrebbe
permettersi di acquistare alcune di
queste macchine e di creare un piccolo
laboratorio creativo a scuola per
esempio oggi si possono comprare delle
stampanti 3d che costano meno di 100
euro e sul fatto che siano tecnicamente
accessibili può garantire un economista
che ha scoperto internet dieci anni fa
nel progetto
siamo partiti da 10 da quattro moduli di
base la programmazione o coding
l'elettronica la stampa 3d e il taglio
laser e i nostri studenti apprendono con
le mani in pasta attraverso il fare e
soprattutto giocando in uno dei nostri
workshop per esempio i studenti creano
un microscopio fai da te con le macchine
taglio laser per la parte di elettronica
di versioni crowe scopi o smontano una
webcam e poi prendono la lente della
webcam e le assemblee non sulla
struttura che hanno tagliato col taglio
laser e poi possono divertirsi a
personalizzare il loro microscopio come
preferiscono durante questo processo di
creazione
gli studenti non solo apprendono il
disegno 2d il taglio laser come smontare
una webcam
anche questa una competenza fondamentale
nell'era digitale ma soprattutto
imparano a vedere la tecnologia come uno
strumento per scoprire il loro intorno
con questo workshop ho visto bambini e
anche adulti correre curiosi per la
strada a raccogliere foglie insetti e
così si cosa strana trovassero ho visto
anche alcuni prendere cotton fioc e
cercare i batteri della bocca da
spalmare sul microscopio e utilizzare
microscopicamente come strumento per
osservare per essere curiosi e in più
questo tipo di progetti sono progetti e
strumenti preziosi per democratizzare la
scienza infatti questi microscopi
costano intorno ai 10 euro e permettono
di avere immagini come questa di qualità
la stessa qualità di microscopi digitali
che costano almeno dieci volte di più
una volta apprese alcune competenze di
base
gli studenti sono liberi di scatenare la
loro immaginazione creando qualsiasi
cosa consigli renault utile o
semplicemente divertente anche piccoli
pokémon e la tecnologia per loro diventa
uno strumento per creare qualcosa di cui
essere orgogliosi
non importa cosa creino importa che
siano loro a crearlo
immaginate se progetti come questo
venissero svolti dagli studenti in tutte
le nostre scuole
immaginate come potrebbe trasformarsi la
nostra educazione se per esempio durante
l'ora di scienza gli studenti non solo
sugli astri battere sul libro ma di
imparassero anche a creare un
microscopio per osservare i batteri che
stanno studiando in questo modo la
tecnologia non diventa una nuova materia
del banchi di scuola ma diventa parte
integrante del curriculum scolastico
come vero e proprio metodo di
apprendimento possiamo portare questo
tipo di educazione digitale creativa in
tutte le nostre scuole con gli altri due
ingredienti del progetto things fall
chiese il team e l'ambiente non possiamo
aspettarci che tutti i nostri insegnanti
si trasformino in esperti digitali da un
giorno all'altro
però possiamo facilitare questa
transizione crea don team che faccia
leva sui teenager nel progetto themes
for kids stiamo formando gli studenti e
le scuole superiori
per essere formatori dei più piccoli
questo approccio ha tanti vantaggi
innanzitutto questi studenti sono nativi
digitali sono cresciuti con la
tecnologia e quindi possono insegnare in
maniera più diretta ai piccoli inoltre
fare leva sui teenager ci permette di
portare l'educazione digitale a scuola a
costi e tempi molto ridotti e quindi di
aumentare esponenzialmente il numero di
studenti che possiamo raggiungere nel
progetto di infor kid quest'anno a
marsala siamo un gruppo di 10 volontari
che stanno formando 100 studenti delle
scuole superiori che durante quest'anno
scolastico formeranno 750 studenti delle
scuole elementari a seconda dei loro
interessi
i suoi delle scuole superiori hanno roll
viversi il nostro progetto
c'è chi svolgere le lezioni ai piccoli
c'è chi ci aiuti a prepararle
ci sono alcuni che stanno traducendo
materiale workshop dall'inglese
all'italiano
e poi c'è un gruppo che ci aiutano a
gestire il progetto come fosse la loro
start up per questi strumenti e le
scuole superiori il nostro progetto e
uno stage formativo che svolgono durante
le ore di alternanza scuola lavoro uno
stage che li sta formando e preparando
al mondo del lavoro ma anche al mondo
fuori dal lavoro in cui potranno godere
di una visione della tecnologia come
strumento di formazione di impegno
sociale e di cambiamento insegnare e
anche il modo migliore per imparare e
questi studenti stiamo diventando
piccoli specialisti digitali alcuni di
loro hanno deciso di continuare a
studiare ai e in aria e scientifiche e
tecnologiche quindi di iscriversi
all'università in queste aree ha
ispirati dalle nostre attività altri
hanno già creato start up innovative a
marsala e una di questa è creata da
teenager ha già 16.000 utenti in tutto
il mondo insieme alla pratica attraverso
la fabbricazione digitale è un team che
fa leva sedi niger
c'è un terzo in mente fondamentale per
formare i giovani creatori l'ambiente e
mentre nella vela l'ambiente dato e non
si può modificare si possono essere
fortunati a nascere e crescere in un
posto baciato dal sole e dal vento in
progetti come things for kids l'ambiente
si può disegnare nel nostro caso
e per creare un ambiente di
apprendimento creativo e per formare i
nostri ragazzi ci siamo affidati alle
risorse disponibili gratuitamente online
incluse quelle da università molto
prestigiose come il mit e stanford
abbiamo selezionato workshop progetti e
interi corsi che stiamo replicando in
sicilia e grazie a queste risorse si
mostra dino educazione digitale creativa
ha così intorno ai 10 euro a studente
un'educazione creativa al costo di un
biglietto per il cinema
questo è il potere che a internet di
rendere un'educazione d'eccellenza
accessibili a tutti in maniera
democratica ed equa ma devo ammettere
che non è stato semplice trovare le
risorse per questi workshop perché
spesso non sono italiano sono sparse tra
veri piattaforma in varie lingue
il progetto team for kids vogliamo
contribuire a rimuovere questo ostacolo
e permettere a tanti altri di buttarsi
in progetti di educazione creativa a
scuola per questo abbiamo deciso di
lanciare una piattaforma online in
italiano dove condividere workshop
progetti e corsi a cui noi ci siamo
affidati per il nostro progetto e anche
quelli che speriamo di replicare in
futuro in modo che chiunque volesse
promuovere un'educazione digitale della
sua realtà locale possa avere un punto
di riferimento da cui partire ma perché
questa piattaforma supporta lighting for
kids faccia veramente la differenza
il nostro contributo da solo non è
sufficiente
lanceremo la piattaforma a gennaio e nel
frattempo vogliamo invitare tutti quelli
che come noi stanno lavorando per
formare giovani creatori a contribuire
alla creazione di questa piattaforma
abbiamo lanciato ieri sera creato da
alcuni studenti che fanno parte del
nostro progetto
un portale online dove invitiamo tutti
tutti quelli che vogliono contribuire al
progetto a condividere con noi progetti
workshop casi pratici lezioni apprese
qualsiasi cosa voglia dire a mettere a
disposizione di tutti attraverso il
portale themes for chiese in questo modo
il portale può diventare un punto di
riferimento da cui partire ma anche un
punto di incontro di scambio di lezioni
apprese e di collaborazione tra varie
persone che vogliono fare la differenza
e portare questo tipo di educazione a
scuola creando una rete
e stato sperimentato nei e condivisione
possiamo far sì che da tanti casi
isolati possa partire una rivoluzione
educativa dal basso insieme possiamo
formare una generazione di creatori di
protagonisti e l'era digitale piuttosto
che dei semplici spettatori di questa
trasformazione
tutti possiamo contribuire a questa
missione un insegnante qui iniziale con
un workshop prendendo dal portale things
for kids e e farlo nella sua classe una
studentessa universitaria o una teenager
possono bussare alle porte di una scuola
elementare e proporsi per fare uno di
questi workshop e da lì si passa poi a
intere scuole e interi comuni e
condividendo questi workshop e le
lezioni apprese sul nostro portale
l'impatto di queste iniziative può
moltiplicarsi
l'attivista berta calloway scriveva che
non si può cambiare la direzione del
vento ma si possono aggiustare le vele
quando si inizia a fare velo normalmente
ci si lascia trascinare dal vento e si
segue la direzione del vento
dopo un po si inizia controllo e la
barca decidere la rotta e anche andare
controvento il vento passa dall'essere
un ostacolo a essere un mezzo per
raggiungere una destinazione con la
pratica attraverso la fabbricazione
digitale con un team che fa leva sui
teenager e con il giusto ambiente
formativo possiamo far sì che questa
generazione di strumenti italiani vede
la tecnologia nella stessa maniera in
cui il velista vede il vento come uno
strumento per raggiungere la loro
destinazione
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]